okay let's get you up to speed now on
the drum and lindsay lohan's love life
yesterday we showed you the explosive
argument she had with her fiance Lindsay
shouted that he strangled her but now it
looks like Lindsay may have told him
that's Lindsay's 20 year old fiancee
Russian multi-millionaire heir igor tara
boss off today moving his things out of
her London home after she accused him of
abuse a source tells ET the man standing
watch is loewen's bodyguard just hired
to prevent Igor from reentering the
apartment so where is Lindsay we're told
she's on a private yacht near Corsica
France
seen here today yesterday a friend
instagrammed this pic captioned hashtag
nothing but love on our hashtag family
vacation while igor has not been charged
with a crime and hasn't been available
for comment
there is another twist the woman in the
middle before the blow-up Lindsay
accused her fiance of cheating with
mutual friend Russian fashion designer
Dasha Pasha Pina instagramming video of
his outing with her and Michael we just
spoke to the designer who denies any
affair and calls Lowen irrationally
jealous Dasha says after her fight
Lindsay quote decided to reveal my
personal information including my home
address and my mobile number
I received death threats from her crazy
fans she adds she's considering taking
legal action unless Loen apologizes
Lindsay is facing criticism she had
begged for privacy instagramming quote
please leave us to be to solve our
personal matters four-page lit up with
comments calling Lindsay a hypocrite for
posting about first her response today
quote I am sorry that I've exposed
certain private matters recently I was
acting out of fear and sadness